une jérôme rodriguez bonsoir je
reprendrai yes merci d'être avec nous en
direct par téléphone sur rtl france tout
d'abord on imagine que vous êtes plutôt
satisfait du départ de christophe
castaner dans l'absolu je dirais que oui
c'est une première satisfaction doublée
d'une déception par la suite forcément
une déception pourquoi parce qu'on
s'aperçoit qu'aujourd'hui nous avons un
nouveau ministre de l'intérieur qui est
tard qu il dit donc très sécuritaire
créé exprès sur la police donc je pense
que la répression aura une autre saveur
mais sera beaucoup plus sévère qu'elle
n'a été sous l'ère castaner et ce qui
est quelque part dérangeant c'est
d'avoir un chef de la police qui
aujourd'hui va diriger les enquêteurs
qui enquête sur des présomptions de deux
degrés de viol ou autre chose et le lion
sexuelles sur la vie d'une femme vous
dites ici il ya une sorte de conflit
d'intérêts parce qu'on le rappelle un
pour les téléspectateurs qui
l'ignoreraient gérald darmanin fait
l'objet actuellement d'une enquête
préliminaire sur des accusations de vol
et souvent non violent à son encontre
pour vous voilà il ne fallait pas qu'il
soit nommé parce qu'il ya une forme de
conflit dans cette affaire non seulement
il ya conflit d'intérêts mais
aujourd'hui où est l'exemple et à
l'exemplarité s'il vous plaît si vous
voulez de 2,2 d'un ministre qui est
visée sur une enquête et qui aujourd'hui
dirige dirige une fonction importante du
gouvernement donc oui il ya offrit
d'intérêt et je pense que c'est une
mauvaise chose et ça donne une nouvelle
fois une mauvaise image de ce que peut
apporter le gouvernement alors vous
dites c'est un sarkozy s'il ya un aspect
très sécuritaire c'est ce que vous
pensez à priori ou voilà vous avez
entendu peut-être des réflexions de la
part de gérald darmanin qui vous
laissent penser que
la ville va être serrer davantage la vis
tu vas être tirée davantage on est
aujourd'hui sur un phénomène où on ne
parle que de sécurité choses qu'ils ne
faisaient pas partie du programme de
macron donc on voit aujourd'hui
l'influencé sarkozyste qui peut y avoir
au sein du gouvernement ne serait ce
qu'à l'échelle du premier ministre et
oui forcément quand on connaît le
discours de l'ancien président sarkozy
on va s'axer vers un régime beaucoup
plus sécuritaire et je pense que la
répression sera beaucoup plus forte
qu'une qu'elle n'a été et on voit
aujourd'hui que le gouvernement
n'apporte toujours pas de réponse quelle
que soit la difficulté qui se peut se
présenter à lui c'est à dire qu'à défaut
de répondre aux citoyens français et
d'importer une justice sociale et
fiscale chose qui est demandé
aujourd'hui par des citoyens en colère
on active d'autant plus la violence et
la répression c'est le schéma
gouvernemental depuis quarante ans quand
on ne peut pas répondre aux citoyens on
applique une répression l'impliquent des
amendes on applique une certaine
violence au sein de ceux qui pourraient
osé élever la voix
clairement qu'elle doit être qu'elles
devraient être selon vous la position de
gérald darmanin dans le dossier sur les
violences policières on sait qu'il ya un
débat qui s'est ouvert notamment autour
du placage ventrale et de la clé
d'étranglement aujourd'hui clairement
vous attendez vous et vos comparses
gilet jaune qui est une prise de
position claire
alors moi la première prise de position
claire pour faire référence à tout ce
qui s'est passé depuis des semaines sur
le débat sur les violences policières
je pense qu'une mesure forte serait
celle de de mettre fin à l'igpn c'est à
dire de pouvoir laisser enquêter un
organisme neutre et à la fois en partial
sur ce qui peut se passer en terme de
violences policières hauts du mois sur
l' enquête pénale dont kate and its
créative fait partie du ressort de la
police nationale il a eu d'enquêté mme
sur l' enquête pénale
il faut aujourd'hui les serres enquêtait
un organisme neutre pour que la justice
puisse faire aujourd'hui la justice est
mal rendu parce que les différentes
enquêtes et les différentes pièces
apportées la justice ne permettent pas
de deux
de m les responsabilités aux policiers
qui font des violences policières
donc ça ce serait une mesure forte a
rapporté îlots mise de l'intérieur
aurait assez de cran pour londres rendre
justice à l'ensemble des personnes qui
sont décédées sous les coups de la
police ou qui ont été malheureusement
mutilé soit respectée social 1 22
novembre 2019 en pleine manifestation
des jd jaune crise des gilets jaunes
voulant montrer plutôt de la compassion
avec ce mouvement gérald darmanin alors
ministre du budget avait affirmé qu'on
ne pouvait pas dîner à paris à moins de
100 euros par personne
120 ha ti les autres est bon de préciser
c'est une déclaration qui vous inquiète
aujourd'hui
ben non ça m'inquiète pas parce que
c'est qui ça ne prouve que la
déconnexion aujourd'hui de 2,9 élites
gouvernementales
tout simplement je veux dire moi je
mangeais pour 120 euros son prix encore
rod je mange pas pour se revoir une
motion paris parce que je serai puisque
j'ai donc on vit pas dans le même monde
on vit pas dans le même monde et on l'a
bien au prix
on l'a bien compris en tout cas de la
part des gens qui nous dirigent
aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui on a clairement vu
jean castex reprendre le dossier des
retraites à bras le corps
la rentrée s'annonce compliquée déjà le
mouvement des gilet jaune
est ce que vous avez prévu déjà des
manifestations des rassemblements pour
septembre alors écoutez pour le coup
c'est la question qu'on me pose le plus
aujourd'hui quand j'ai l'occasion de me
promener dans la rue ou de faire
quelques courses là plus la pluie la
plus impressionnante des discussions que
j'ai pu avoir avec deux policiers qui
sont venus me voir et si on salue et qui
nous ont demandés alors qu'ils estiment
à 3 quand c'est le temps qu'est ce que
vous pensez reprendre et la réponse a
été la suivante aujourd'hui je compte il
ne faut pas avoir peur des gilet jaune
pourquoi parce que les gilets jaunes
connaissent la misère déjà depuis des
années et ça ce que c'est la misère donc
un peu plus elle sera beaucoup plus
douloureuses mais aujourd'hui vous allez
avoir des gens qui vont arriver en
septembre dans une misère qui n'ont
jamais connu et qui n'ont jamais eu je
lirai là ma chance de pouvoir la goûter
et c'est ces gens là qui seront
peut-être les plus dangereux quand ils
vont faire face à toutes les difficultés
qui vont se présenter à eux ne serait-ce
que celle du chômage pour pas oublier
que de multiples
ils vont fermer que des petits patrons
eux ne seront pas au chômage et ne
reçoit bon rien et ce seront peut-être
que les plus dangereux
merci beaucoup jérôme rodriguez en tout
cas d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur
arte france